si tenemos seis mil 798 menos tres mil
359 como vamos a saber la respuesta
hemos marcado en colores distintos las
clasificaciones que hemos usado en
vídeos previos unidades decenas centenas
y unidades de millar vamos a hacer el
análisis como lo hemos hecho columna por
columna sin embargo me gusta hacer
primero un análisis general 3359 sin
duda es más pequeño que seis mil 798 lo
que nos dice que esta resta la podemos
hacer sin problemas y nos saldrá bien
ahora vámonos columna por columna en la
en la columna de las unidades tenemos
que el 8 es más pequeño que el 9 por lo
que vamos a requerir un préstamo de la
columna de las decenas el 9 es más
grande que el 5 estamos bien
es más grande que el 3 vamos bien y 6 es
más grande que el 3 estamos bien hagamos
la separación o la reinterpretación por
grupos vamos a agrupar este mismo número
estos mismos números y tenemos que 6 mil
798 es igual a 6000
más 700
más 90 + 8 esto ustedes ya lo conocen
entonces haremos lo mismo con el número
de abajo 3359 es igual a 3000 más 300
más 50 más 9 ok vamos bien lo que
haremos ahora entonces es este 8 va a
ocupar que le prestemos desde el 90
porque es mucho más pequeño que el 9 lo
que haremos es entonces cambiar este 90
a 80 y este 8 a 18 no estamos cambiando
los números van a decir oye estás
haciendo trampa me estás cambiando los
números sin embargo si sumamos 6.700 más
80 18 es igual a 6 mil 798 si lo hacemos
más más sencillo veremos que 90 más 8 es
igual a 98
de la misma manera que hoy 80 18 es
igual a 98 ahora tenemos un 18 que es
mayor que el 9 180 que es mayor que el
50 700 que es mayor a 300 y un 6000 que
es mayor a 3000 ahora podemos hacer
nuestra respectiva resta 18 menos 9 es
igual a 9
vamos a poner la línea de separación de
la resta 18 menos 9 es igual a 9 como ya
habíamos visto 80 menos 50 es igual a 30
setecientos menos trescientos es igual a
400 y 6000 menos 3.000 es igual a 3000
si sumamos este número tres mil 439 nos
dará tres mil 439 veamos de este lado
como lo haríamos directamente recuerdan
aquella frase de hagámoslo como examen
pues así a este 8 voy a ocupar prestarle
desde el 9 cambiar este 9 por 18 vamos a
cambiar el color para que sea el de las
decenas
este se volverá un 8 y le estoy
prestando 10 a las unidades por lo que
este de este 8 se vuelve 18 8 es mayor
que 5 podemos restar 7 es mayor que 3
podemos restar 6 es mayor que 3 podemos
restar vámonos con los resultados 18
menos nueve es igual a nueve
8 5 es igual a 37 menos 3 es igual a 4
mientras que 6 menos tres es igual a 3
llegamos exactamente al mismo número que
habíamos hecho previamente recuerden que
esto lo que busca es que entendamos que
no estamos cambiando los números
simplemente estamos reagrupando los para
que logremos hacer nuestra red nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo